[Musique]
bonsoir à tous lundi 20 novembre
bienvenue dans le 78 sur tv78 voici les
titres de
l'actualité un ministre dans les
evvelines ce matin Jean-Noël Barot s'est
rendu au château de Buc le ministre
délégué chargé du numérique a présidé
une rencontre sur les enjeux de
l'inclusion numérique dans le
département des Yvelines l'occasion
d'échanger avec les conseillers
numériques qui ont accompagné 13000
yvelinois sur le sujet du sport et de la
solidarité au menu d'une journée à
Montini le Bretonneux la Ville a
organisé un événement ce weekend au
profit des Restos du cœur qui ouvre
demain leur 39e campagne d'hiver au menu
notamment un tournoi international un
tournoi national de hand fauteuil
l'exploit n'a pas eu lieu en Coupe de
France de football les amateurs de
houille ont été éliminés au 7e tour par
ranger pensionnaire de la Ligue 2 2 les
engevins beaucoup plus réalistes l'ont
emporté de but à Z0 contre le club
yvilinois il était l'ultime représentant
du département dans la compétition et
puis l'invité du 78 en 2uxème partie
d'émission on y parle du dispositif
champion 2024 le département des
ivelines accompagne 15 athlètes de haut
niveau dans leur projet sportifs le but
les mettre en avant à l'approche des
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
Paris
2024 et à Sylvain mertins chef du
service sport du département des
ivelines sera avec avec nous dans
quelques instants pour parler de ce
dispositif champion 2024 qui s'adresse
aussi au club du département avec moi au
plateau Michel midoro bonsoir
journaliste sport de la rédaction tv78
ça va pas trop déçu après l'élimination
de ouille en Coupe de France c'est la la
magie de la Coupe de France on y a cru
on y a cru et finalement ça passe pas
toujours comme on a pu le voir alors
bien sûr d'autres résultats sportifs au
menu de ce weekend yvelinois on va
parler de quoi ce soir dans le 78 de
défait encore trois clubs yvlinois été
engagés en fait éral 2 et les trois
clubs evilinois ont perdu on parlera
quand même de la course
transatlantique la transat Jacques wabre
avec Louis Burton qui est actuellement
15e et qui arrive en Martinique ça c'est
une information positive pour le coup et
vous présenterez aussi les actualités du
jour dans les evines restez avec nous ce
sera tout à l'heure dans le
78 ce chiffre 1 Français sur 3 est
aujourd'hui éloigné du numérique
l'Agence nationale de la cohésion des
territoires déploie Ave actuellement
France Numérique ensemble une feuille de
route qui prévoit la création de postes
de conseiller numérique ils sont 30 à
avoir été recrutés dans différentes
collectivités et ce matin le ministre
délégué chargé du numérique Jean-Noël
Barot est allé à Laur rencontre à Buc
Mélanie poquet et Patrick Jacques de
dixm il se trouvit totalement démuni
lorsqu'on se retrouve face à une
démarche en ligne face à la préparation
d'un CV France Numérique ensemble trois
mots pour lutter contre la fracture
numérique une feuille de route qui cour
jusqu'en 2027 et le département des
Yvelines est aussi concerné un excellent
retour puisque c'est 3 millions de
personnes qui ont été accompagnées au
plan national 13000 dans les Yvelines
avec évidemment de l'aide pour accomplir
les démarches en ligne mais aussi et
surtout pour prendre en main les outils
numériques et permettre à chacun de
bénéficier de tout ce que le le
numérique apporte de positif pour
améliorer la vie quotidienne ceux qui
aideent ce sont les conseillers
numériques au nombre de 4000 sur toute
la France ils sont 30 à être actif dans
le département des ivelines au sein des
collectivités locales les conseils
numériques on peut les trouver à la fois
en mairie dans le des associations aussi
et également dans des bibliothèques ou
dans des médiathèques donc c'est l'idée
c'est vraiment qu'il puisse aussi se
déplacer au maximum pour être à la
rencontre des habitants je fais aussi
bien des
sensibilisations spécifiquement pour les
écoles que des accompagner les parents
pour ma part voire même aussi les
enseignants dans la maîtrise du
numérique des tablettes numérique qui
ont un programme qui a été renouvelé
encore cette année je peux aller à
domicile et c'est quelque chose que je
fais souvent puisque les gens apprécier
être accompagné dans leur lieu familial
on va dire dans dans leur foyer objectif
du plan en 2027 avoir accompagn 8
millions de Français avec 20000
conseillers le point à présent sur le
reste des actualités dans les
ivelines ce lundi novembre marquait la
journée internationale des droits de
l'enfant et dans les Yvelines Michel
plusieurs communes sont engagées pour
cette thématique oui et pour preuve de
cet engagement plusieurs villes
ivelinoises disposent du titre de ville
amie des enfants mise en place par
l'UNICEF parmi elles carrière souspoiss
con flan saint-onorine guyencour marleri
moropam rambouillé ou encore hlencour
après avec près de 300 collectivités
engagées sur le mandat 2020- 2026 le
réseau accompagne les collectivités
locales pour promouvoir les droits de
l'enfant cinq domaines sont sont pris en
compte le bien-être la non
discrimination et l'égalité l'éducation
la participation et la sensibilisation
aux droits de l'enfant une alerte
maintenant l'agence régionale de santé
d'Île-de-France recommande de ne pas
consommer les œufs des poulaillers
domestiques oui et cela en raison d'un
niveau élevé de contamination des œufs
par différents polluants dangereux pour
la santé d'après une étude de l'ARS en
Île-de-France 90 % des œufs analysés
seraient non conforme des contaminations
sont liées à la présence dans le sol de
polluants organiques persistants les
œufs sont des marqueur très révélateur
de la pollution de l'environnement et en
particulier des sols les recommandations
de l'ARS concernent 410 villes en
île-defanceance dans les ivelines
plusieurs communes sont touchées c'est
notamment le cas de poissie mantelajolie
ou encore Versailles prudence donc pour
les consommateurs direction maintenant
Rouillet où les habitants vont pouvoir
très prochainement avoir un un nouveau
cinéma depuis 2019 les rambolitains
n'ont plus de cinéma dans leur commune
depuis la destruction du Vox si un
projet de construction était prévu après
la pandémie en en 2021 il avait
finalement été abandonné au grand
désarrois des habitants mais la bonne
nouvelle est finalement arrivée fin juin
2023 la société Sarles l'Ermitage a
racheté le terrain et un permis de
construire a été déposé et signé
l'ouverture au public serait prévu pour
la rentrée scolaire 2025 disposant de
CIN salles le complexe sera reconstruit
sous le Porsche de la rue De Gaulle les
villes de Versailles et Saint-Germain au
lait distingué le site villederêve.fr a
rendu son classement des villes où il
fait bon vivre dans la catégorie des
villes mois on retrouve versaill en 2e
position et saint-ganmanl en 5e position
parmi les nombreux critères pris en
compte pour établir ce classement la
qualité de vie le patrimoine ou encore
l'accès à la nature et à la santé et on
termine avec une information insolite
Michel oui une information insolite et
une image qu' est tout autant une courge
tenez-vous bien Grégory d' 1,20 pour 44
kg a été récolté dans les ivblines à
l'origine ce sont des graines de courge
musqué napolitaine provenant d'un voyage
en Italie qui ont été plantés dans la
serre municipale don sur moldre vous
vous en doutez personne ne s'attendait à
un tel résultat Thierry auchard le
conseiller municipal de la commune en
charge de l'environnement et responsable
de la SER a suggéré de faire avec cette
courge une grande soupe pour le marché
de Noël les habitants pourraient donc
aussi en profiter de C impressionnante
image pour terminer ces actualités du
jour merci beaucoup Michel et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi près de chez
vous vous êtes témoins d'une actualité
qui vous fait réagir dans les evvelines
n'hésitez pas à la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
78 news
[Musique]
le projet de loi immigration va être
débattu de nouveau à l'Assemblée
nationale les députés se se pencheront
sur le texte à partir du 27 Novembre
dans ce texte l'article 3 prévoit la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papiers exerçant des métiers dit en
tension cet article ainsi que l'aide
médicale d'État pour ces travailleurs
ont été pourtant supprimé du projet de
loi par les sénateurs qui ont durci le
texte en première lecture Ibrahim tal
qui est animateur de la question des
travailleurs sans papier la CGT 78
explique pourquoi selon lui le maintien
de cet article est primordial dans le
projet de loi interview
[Musique]
express ces métiers entention euh sont
en général dans la restauration mais
aussi dans le BTP cela veut dire euh les
maçons euh les peintres les monounisiers
mais aussi euh les les ceux qui font les
manœuvres dans la logistique également
donc donc on a besoin dans la logistique
aujourd'hui mais aussi la propreté fait
partie des métiers
[Musique]
intention faciliter la régularisation de
ces gens qui occupent déjà les métiers
ils sont déjà en poste donc ils
travaillent ils sont en poste ils
cotisent donc il faut les régulariser
aujourd'hui faire l'article c'est que
les patrons ne seront plus là à être les
les les véritables euh moteurs pour
régulariser parce qu'il y a les SERFA
les promesses d'embos qu'il fallait
remplir par les par les patrons donc une
fois que ça passe cela veut dire que la
régularisation ne va plus dépendre des
patrons il y a une contradiction en en
sur la question de supprimer l'ame pour
établir l'aide médicale d'urgence il y a
une contradiction si c'est pour des
questions économiques c'est que c'est
contradictoire parce que au lieu de
soigner euh le travailleur sans papier
ou le sang- papier tout court eu à à un
tau de 21 € il faut attendre que ça soit
urgent pour le payer des soins qui vaut
200 à 500 € donc il y a une
contradiction cette galère cette boule
au ventre ça ça ne s'arrête jamais parce
qu'au renouvellement on demande
l'autorisation de travail ça doit faire
ça doit être faite par le patron qui
doit envoyer à la plateforme euh service
madœuvre étrangère sauf que ça prend du
temps et on ce ce qu'on voit c'est que
les gens deviennent sans papier parce
qu'ils n'ont pas eu l'autorisation de
travail faite par le patron pourquoi
parce que certaines boîtes ne cotisent
pas à l'irsaf les autres c'est les
problèmes des rendez-vous on n'arrive
pas à avoir les rendez-vous c'est saturé
voilà ce que V vraiment euh les les
travailleurs étrangers que ce soit sans
papier et les travailleurs déjà
[Musique]
régularisés on ouvre la page sport dans
le
[Musique]
du sport mais aussi de la solidarité au
menu d'un événement organisé à Montini
le Bretonneux depuis 13 ans c'est la
journée sport et solidarité qui se
déroulait donc ce weekend au profit des
Restos du cœur au programme notamment un
tournoi national de hand fauteuil suivi
par Mathilde Francou le récit de de
Régine
ralch le hand fauteuil à l'honneur un
tournoi se tenait ce samedi 18 novembre
à Montini le Bretonneux au total six
équipes mixtes de personnes en situation
de handicap et valide se sont affrontés
toute la journée c'est donné aussi une
possibilité aux personnes valides de
d'avoir un changement de vue sur le
handicap se rendre compte que c'est des
gens comme vous et moi et que voilà on
peut on peut bien profiter et bien
s'amuser avec eux il y en a ils viennent
pour le pour s'amuser et moi je fais du
sport depuis 40 ans donc j'ai un esprit
de compétition tout le temps je veux
gagner en fait une solidarité sur le
terrain mais aussi de la part des
visiteurs ils étaient plusieurs
centaines à se rendre à l'événement et
participer à la collecte de fonds mise
en place pour l'association Les Restos
du cœur c'est important déjà pour se
faire connaître et puis comme C au
manque d'argent en ce moment on va être
obligé de restreindre sur la campagne
qui arrive la quantité de nourriture le
nombre de personnes accepté et donc plus
on a d'argent plus on pourra aider un
espoir entendu par les participants
l'événement a collecté plus de 4300 €
pour l'antenne
yvelinoise les résultats sportifs du
weekend c'est avec vous Michel elmidor
on commence par du football et la Coupe
de France c'était le match à ne pas
manquer ce weekend dans les ivines ou
qui évolue en régional 1 a joué ce
samedi contre anger un club de Ligue 2
malgré une très belle prestation le
dernier représentant yvelinois dans la
compétition s'est incliné sur le score
de 2 buts à 0 avec les honneurs le
résumé du match des images de Mathilde
Francou c'était le match des grands
jours à ouille pour ce 7e tour de la
Coupe de France le club local
pensionnaire de R1 recevait les
professionnels d'Anger ce samedi 18
novembre une équipe qui évolue en Ligue
2 après 45 minutes très équilibré sur un
terrain humide ce sont finalement les
visiteurs qui ouvrent le score grâce à
lois dionny 1-0 ce sera le score à la
aussi ça manquait un peu de d'intensité
on jouait pas les coups à fond mais mais
on fais des jeux égal et on prend un
but qui pas forcément mérité sur une une
erreur
d'appréciation et c'est les détails qui
qui compent à ce niveul-là la première
période était une priode de qualité
voilà on a réussi à jouer au ballon à
produire du jeu et c'était intéressant à
se procurer quelques situations
dangereuses en seconde période ou
n'abdique pas tant d'égaliser ce procure
des situations mais ce sont finalement
les engevins qui font le break à la 90e
minute suite à ce penalty 2 à 0 la
logique a été respecté ce samedi sur
cette pelouse ivinoise aujourd'hui le
petit poussé ne renversera pas un gros
on peut être fier de ce qu'on a ce qu'on
a fait on joue contre une division qui a
5 niveaux auudessus du NRE je
m'attendais à une victoire je
m'attendais une victoire peu importe
l'adversaire encore une fois je lu dis
sur un match il peut tout se passer
c'est aussi le charm de la la Coupe de
France les les conditions nous étaient
favorables après voilà tout est dans
l'intensité et dans le réalisme
tactiquement techniquement c'est évident
que il y a une classe d'écart et et ça
se voit en tout cas lorsque nous sommes
sur le terrain maintenant aujourd'hui
avec de la volonté avec plein de choses
on a réussi à combler ces petits manques
et à montrer que sur 90 minutes on peut
essayer de rivaliser ou devra maintenant
se reconcentrer sur le championnat de R1
les ivinois occupent pour l'instant la
9e place du classement après 6 journées
disputé bon bravo tout de même au club
de ou qui s'est quand même Issé jusqu'au
7e tour de la Coupe de France mais
petite déception plus club ivlinois de
de d'orénavant en Coupe de France on va
parler maintenant rugby Michel dans le
championnat de fédéral 2 plaisir s'est
incliné 31 à 28 sur sa pelouse dans le
choc de cette poou contre orsé de son
côté Versailles s'est incliné 36 à 28
sur son tetin contre risoris et enfin le
MLSGP c'est incliné 23-19 à domicile
contre jeunevillier vous l'aurez compris
c'est un weekend noir pour nos ivelinois
trois matchs et trois défaites au
classement plaisir est toujours premier
mais le le club ne compte que deux
points d'avance sur l'heureux et HS
versaill est 8e et le MLSGP est 9e on
continue par du basket dans le
championnat de National 3 trap s'est
incliné 89 à 76 sur le terrain de céser
l vilain ce samedi soir l'entente le
chîn et Versailles s'est inclinée d'un
point contre r 76 à 75 enfin châau
croissi a gagné 84 à 75 contre Massi au
classement Trapp est 10e et le LCV 78
est 13e et châau croissie et bon dernier
basket toujours mais féminin mauvais
weekend pour le LCV 78 on a vu que les
garçons avaient perd perdu et les filles
ont également perdu ce weekend les
ibinois se sont inclinés 77 à 55 sur le
terrain des Panthères de mulouse au
classement le LCV 78 est toujours dans
le top 5 à la 4e place du classement
Duan bal à présent peut-être une bonne
nouvelle dans le championnat oui oui
tout à fait dans le championnat de
National 2 Montini le Bretonneux s'est
imposé ce weekend sur le terrain d'élite
valdoise le score 31 à 2 la joueuse du
match roman Damiens qui a marqué 14 buts
sur cette partie au classement les
centinois sont à à la 8e place avec 17
points engrangé en 10 journées et chez
les garçons ça va très bien pour le club
du chînet le chînet Evelin handbal s'est
imposé ce dimanche 19 novembre sur le
terrain de Saint-Sébastien sport le
score 26 à 22 romain large a brillé avec
8 buts inscrits sur cette renconte cette
nouvelle victoire permet au club de
rester en tête du classement de la
pooule 4 de National 3 ça tombe bien on
va prendre le large à présent avec la
trans Jack V uninois est encore en
course dans cette course transatlantique
c'est Louis Burton le skiiper originaire
de là à bord à côté de rambouill est
actuellement à la 15e place du
classement au dernier pointage il est
presque arrivé en Martinique avec son
coéquipier David Baudard nous a
enregistré une petite vidéo
regardez salut les Ies c'estton
bienvenue surall alors c'est vous desard
qui n suivent est de l'autre côté de la
caméra on est à quelques encavrur de
l'arrivée en martinque maintenant on a
fait une option Nord pour essayer de
rattraper un peu notre retard sur les
concurrents pénalé au départ et ça fait
de jours qu'on descend tout droit sud
vers la Martinique
avec assez instable là on est V dans un
Ro et
sinon la rencontre des poissons volant
on na pas croisé grand monde et on
surveille attentiement les conurents
pour essayer de les doubler ce qui reste
un peu sur la fin voilà et bureauvallé
en parfaite état donc bah on est content
on aura
presque réussi à s f de ce point de vu
là donc voilà c'est parfait à
bientôt bon Louis Burton devrait arriver
dans un peu moins de 48 heur en
Martinique arrivée imminente de Louis
Burton et vous aussi hein sur la version
alors justement je suis en compétition
avec Louis Burton parce que dans la
rédaction personne n'est arrivé à mon
niveau toujours en tête dans dans la
rédaction dans dans la version virtuelle
de la Transat javab on termine avec un
mot de tennis en dis sport à feroll ce
jeudi débute le tour BNP pariba
wheelshare tournament du comité des
Evelin un rendez-vous qui regroupe des
joueurs et joueuses du de tennis
fauteuil venu du monde entier à
l'occasion de ces matchs qui se
dérouleront au Comité des iines de froll
on pourra voir sur le terrain les stars
françaises de la discipline Pauline
deroued et Charlotte ferban les finales
sont programmées ce dimanche au comité
merci Michel et avant de passer à
l'invité du 78 coup d'œil aux prévisions
météo de
demain un ciel brumeux demain matin dans
les ziveline ce sera le cas sur une
grande partie du territoire côté
température compté 9°gr dans les
secteurs de Versailles et de Rambouillet
10°gr à montelajolie et Oudan
l'après-midi le brouillard se lève mais
le temps reste très gris il fera entre
11 et 13°gr dans les ivelines et tout de
suite l'invité du
[Musique]
78 j- 200 49 avant les Joos de Paris
2024 en rédaction on suit avec attention
ce comptearbour les zivelines seront
centrales pendant cet événement he
puisque le département accueille 10
épreuves olympiques et paralympique pour
cette échéance des Jeux Olympiques et on
paralympique de Paris 2024 dans ce cadre
le département des evelines a lancé un
dispositif qui s'appelle champion 2024
15 sportifs de haut niveau sont
accompagnés par la collectivité et on en
parle avec justement l'invité du 78
c'est Sylvain mertins bonsoir vous êtes
chef du service sport du département des
ibines bah tout simplement déjà pourquoi
avoir créé ce dispositif alors c'est à
la fois pour aider les athlètes dans
leur préparation dans leur préparation
pour les Jeux Olympiques de Paris 2024
voir au-delà sur Los Angeles aussi en
2028 mais au-delà d'une aide en fait
c'est c'est vraiment un dispositif de
soutien pour que ces
athlètes parlent de leur sport mais
surtout en en fait défendre des valeurs
auprès des publics pour lequel le
département engage son action et ça
c'est
fondamental au-delà du soutien c'est
vraiment quelque part un un deal qu'on a
pu avoir avec ces ces athlètes pour
qu'ils aillent au plus près des
publics qui sont prioritaires pour le
département l'idée c'est de créer un
engouement autour aussi de cette
échéance olympique qu'on ne verra
peut-être qu'une fois dans une vie sur
le territoire français les chance
olympiques les les Jeux d'été la
dernière fois c'éta en 1924 c'était en
1924 avec quelques épreuves dans les
yvilines aussi même en
1924 et ces athlètes vraiment on
souhaite les mettre en avant et et on
souhaite effectivement qu'il a cet
engouement euh auprès des athlètes que
les que les inois reconnaissent les
athlètes de leur territoire et les
soutiennent pendant les Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques de Paris 2024 alors
quand on regarde la liste de ces 15
sportifs alors c'est assez varié il y a
des sports olympiques paralympiques on
peut citer parce que nous on les a suivi
aussi dernièrement Guillaume Chen qui a
été champion olympique par équipe de de
judo à Tokyo Christopher qui est
médaillée de bronze à Toky en équitation
ou encore pour en citer aussi la boxeuse
Rima Yadi du côté des sports
paralympiques là aussi la parapongiste
Lucie hatière la joueuse de tennis
fauteuil Pauline des rOued ou encore
Alex Portal qui a été médaillé d'argent
et et de bronze en en attation au
dernier Jeux Paralympique de Tokyo
comment ont-ils été choisis ces athlètes
alors ils ont fait acte de candidature
dans un premier temps et ensuite on a
essayé d'avoir une variété de de
sportifs qui représentent tout les
sports enfin une majorité de sports dont
les sports les plus iconiques dans les
dans les ivelines je pense à
l'équitation je pense au golf et je
pense évidemment au au cyclisme on a
essayé de voir voilà comment comment il
pouvait occuper tout le territoire euh
et on a essayé d'équilibrer entre des
athlètes olympiques et paralympiques et
ensuite ce qui nous importait c'était ce
que ces athlètes souhaitaient défendre
en terme de valeur vers quel public il
souhaitait s'adresser donc effectivement
on a été assez attentif aux athlètes qui
avaient un message à faire passer auprès
des des des publics de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance par exemple qui qui se
sentaient aussi d'aller au contact des
publics en situation de handicap qui qui
souhaitait qui avait la volonté de
d'aller aussi dans des établissements
scolaires dans des collèges voilà on a
fait ce choix sur un équilibre à la fois
territorial un équilibre de sport et un
équilibre aussi sur les valeurs que ces
athlètes souhaitaient défendre
d'ailleurs il y a aussi Jérémy rosier
qui est un arbitre international de
rugby donc c'est des sportifs et c'est
aussi ceux qui font le sport en général
exactement c'est ceux qui font le sport
et en 2023 la Coupe du Monde de de rugby
s'est déroulé en France jéréy est un
athlète enfin il est dans les listes
mystérial des athlètes de haut niveau et
c'est important aussi d'avoir cet
athlète et il est il est arbitre de Top
14 mais il est aussi arbitre de rugby à
7 qui sera discipline olympique pendant
les Jos oui je je pour les pour les
athlètes ce sont pas forcément des
athlètes qui vont aller forcément sur
ces Jeux olympiques de 2024 on est
d'accord non on cherchait pas on
cherchait pas à avoir des athlètes qui
qui sont des déjà enfin qu' toute la
lumière mais on voulait des athlètes
comme je l'ai expliqué tout à l'heure
qui qui voulaient défendre en fait des
des valeurs qui avaient un sens qui
avait un message à faire passer voilà et
ça c'était fondamental dans le choix que
que le département a pu a pu porter sur
certains athlètes on parlait
d'accompagnement comment sont-ils
justement accompagnés on imagine
financièrement à quelle hauteur alors
c'est 8000 € par athlète sur la saison
sportive
2324 et puis on les accompagne enfin il
a a il y a quelqu'un dans l'équipe du
service sport euh qui a en contact
toutes les semaines avec ses athlètes
pour essayer de de de les suivre euh
dans leur dans leur compétition mais
aussi de les accompagner sur des
événements ou des dispositifs que le
département euh mène euh je pense
notamment aux enfants de l'aide sociale
à l'enfance ù voilà département a créé
une une une académie on va dire
d'excellence en direction de ses de ses
enfants et et d'essayer de faire en
sorte que des athlètes rencontrent ses
enfants donc on est euh vraiment dans
dans cette mécanique
quotidienne voilà pour pour pour faire
briller à la fois ses athlètes en
parlant d'eux mais aussi que que des que
des publics se reconnaissent à travers
ses athlètes et apprennent comprennent
des parcours de vie ok est de la
rencontre des émulations peut-être aussi
susciter des des passions au sein des
des jeunes du coup bah s'il y a une
médaille c'està dire que le département
il sera pour quelque chose oui j'espère
effectivement les les médailles voilà
sont importantes euh participer aussi à
un événement d'ampleur internationale
voilà c'est quelque chose d'an euh mais
moi nous ce qui nous intéresse c'est
c'est c'est l'avant en fait quelque part
on espère bien sûr que ces athlètes
obtiennent des des médailles he pour le
département pour pour promouvoir leur
sport mais ce qui intéresse le le
département c'est tout ce qui va se
passer avant et puis on espère que des
histoires vont se construire entre voilà
certains publics et ses athlètes donc il
se mettent aussi au service du
département la dit avec des rencontres
qui sont organisées alors on a parlé des
athlètes mais le dispositif champion de
2024 s'adresse aussi au club il y a
champion club et ça peut à peu près le
le même principe pour les clubs il y a
un accompagnement aussi c'est un petit
peu le même principe al c'est un appel à
candidature aussi et cette année le
Département soutient une vingtaine de
clubs sur la saison sportive 23 24 euh
et ces clubs ont postulé euh parce
qu'ils avaient des projets et ils
avaient des projets pour développer le
sport en quartier prioritaire politique
de la ville pour développer des sections
parasportives pour développer la
pratique du sport féminin dans des
disciplines qui ne le sont pas encore
malheureusement assez voilà c'est
vraiment des clubs qui avaient des
projets et ce qui est important pour le
département c'est pas tant que ces clubs
soient en première division ou 2è
division ce qui est important pour le
département c'est que ces clubs est un
message aussi à faire passer et et soit
développer leur activité au bénéfice du
sport pour tous les publics et ça c'est
c'est vraiment fondamental et le
département se positionne sur cette
ligne directrice et là encore au niveau
des sports il y a une représentation
large
des sports des clubs qui sont concernés
oui on a été attentif à ce que à ce
qu'un maximum de sport soit soit
représenté il y a aussi bien du rugby du
tennis de
table voilà du du du cyclisme et on a
essayé de veiller aussi à ce que tous
les clubs soient bien répartis sur le
sur le département pour qu'ensuite ces
clubs a des actions parce qu' souvent
les clubs ont des actions dans leur dans
leur zone de dans le zone d'action et
voilà c'est important que ça rayonne que
ce dispositif rayonne un maximum sur le
territoire donc accompagnement des clubs
des athlètes au sein de ce dispositif
champion 2024 d'ailleurs il n'y a pas
d'erreur voilà on le précise dans
l'orthographe champion il y a le Y qui a
pris la place du I pour bien sûr faire
un petit clin d'œil au Département des
ivin merci en tout cas Sylvain mertins
d'être venu en parler sur ce plateau je
rappelle que vous êtes le chef du
service sport au Département des ivines
merci également à Michel de m'avoir
accompagné sur cette demi-heure
d'émission voilà c'est la fin du 78
merci pour votre fidélité nouvelle
édition demain et ce sera avec Régine
ralche très belle soirée sur
[Musique]
tv78